l a tutti i ragazzi sono parigi oggi
siamo sia sono morto
non sapevo neanche di poter morire qua
siamo ragazzi tornati supporti per fare
elementare scape sai che cos'è e cosa
dove ti prendi in ghiaccio la nice in
faccia entra allora elementare skype
dovrebbe essere una specie non dovrebbe
essere troppo difficile né troppo lungo
infatti torino fino in un episodio è un
escape quindi devi utilizzare la tua
mente per riuscire ad arrivare alla fine
amico mio let's go crea dovrebbe essere
una specie di parkour mista labirinto
misto a qualsiasi altra roba
diciamo che si parte in diciamo che si
parte che non si capisce già niente
aiuto i pipistrelli esattori uso il cubo
così poco si può così pur aveva il 3
suoni fiamm usare l'olio al registro di
carico
mara che pinga eccola l'unica è l'unica
solution ragazzi va dagli ultimi lo ha
giocato c'è una trappola
c'è una ok seval 26 stato bravi siamo
stati due geni incre raga mi dissocio da
pietro non so come altro descrivere
questa cosa e se è così bello di questa
mappa che il tipo ha creato una cosa
difficile da fare ma allo stesso tempo
ha creato delle delle poesie di inglese
che non capisci ma è bello sentir lei
mamma mi ha scritto che fai schifo
andiamo avanti ragazza c'è un corso dove
devi fare immagino il parkour tipo
normale miglioro bravissimo esatto bravo
bravo
mamma mia che giocatore è proprio lui
allora devi fare esattamente come stai
facendo non così devi fare il parkour
come stai facendo adesso solo che può
piacere a farlo quello di proprio non
devo morire esatto la devi morire
esattamente saranno di qua poi di qua
poi devi fare questo salto che non ho
capito bene come farlo giusto
la donna guarda dai fari si può fare per
te ma non lo so se lo dico io ce l'ho
fatta amico ce la porta sono passati si
aspetta non badare lei chiama my friends
rea
va bene basta continua
mamma mia che pro gamer e poi una volta
arrivato qua non so dove devo andare
però aiuto madonna ma è difficilissimo
raga ma io continua a morire ma una cosa
veramente il listino è veramente un
casino ragazzi giuro ragazzi veramente
assurdo allora qua qua perfetto ma
hammam in arte giocatore è nova amico io
spero di arrivare al check point perché
incredibili se muoio poi non so come ci
arrivo e teorico e penso devo farlo e
migliora la gravità di un possibile non
so come ho fatto finora
forse devo andare il mio sei
rassicurante comunque mico bravissimo
bravissimo gravissimo lo ricorda solo
bravi mamma mi ha portato facendo un
pazzo un pazzo no se mi passate il
aspetta e poi da quando domanda a ok
mio dio sono fortissimo dovevo andare a
ok cina palermo cerca mercato a dir la
sua caverna tensione perché c'è point lo
voglio lo voglio adesso amico mi sa che
c'è check point sotto muoviti ad
arrivare o meglio non è colpa io la
cortesia
sì però siamo sicuri siete qua non c'è
un'altra strada
non lo so fai con le hai capito in bocca
io ho nell'angolino mi sono buttato
io sono caduto sul fondo però sono vivo
aiutarla no
esatto perché rarissimo farlo anche
prima grazia e troviamo sinistra grazie
creatori del gioco
no grazie non so come ringraziarvi
grazie che figata
purché non in cui si sforano cus bari e
non sparano bike a terra ma qualcosa
cosa vuol dire abc 6 15 18 5 20 m
oltre alle due potenze abc allora devi
devi utilizzare e l'alfabeto pietro
alfabeto quella roba chiusi per le
lettere a b c d e f la prima mettere mf
e fg il 6 la sesta lettera toilette c'è
scritto forever per sempre saremo chiusi
quel grazie a viverle siamo chiusi del
livello per sempre o decifrato alfabeto
americano sono bravo tenore a fare la
spia andare a fare la spesa che devo
capire dopo due anni ma guardando come
scusa
niente di me ma bravissimo che trova le
cose a jean labirinto amparo labyrinth
harbour ricaduta che ci sono ci sono ci
sono solo ci sono sei
ci sono amico ci sono sono di nuovo al
check point 4 che non fosse preso meno
prove ciao raga è stato un casino voglio
morire ma no aspetta ora che non era
quella sinistra di homo vista ci sono
tanto non morto esatto proprio quello
che sto per dirvi moriamo quello di
destra e uno di essi controllano bene
però che quello totale di destra ok ok
allora non era quella di su non era
quella che ho preso che abbiamo preso in
due era l'altra se viene indicato
effetto dritto dovrà farlo demonio non
di sopra era tori andato a destra queste
sono morto tocca a sinistra
ok destra no non era il timore è da non
si muore
loro sì ok dopo che dopo adesso si muore
ora abbiamo possiamo uomini andiamo a
sinistra si muove destra poi come fai a
saperlo e il suo locale già fatto io né
vero non è proprio scommettitori non ci
credo non ci credo ci avevi ragione c'è
poi ragazzi incredibile bravo pietro vi
siamo usciti pesci e xi e xix mio dio
raga che cacano è un parkour levi allora
devi stare qua innanzi tutto questo
sicuro di fare un po di giri porco
demonio porco porco demonio porco porco
demonio porco non so se si è capito come
il demonio e porco hai rotto il masso
e non sono il masso perfetto e poi
d'acqua devi andare sul palco è
difficile molto difficile non apre
fattibile ma bravo come fatto è saltato
di kg è saltato di fila non lo so spiega
mi sono fatto anche io ce l'ho fatta chi
lo aspetta come fatto fare dall'albero
bellissimo va bene
bravissimo mamma mia non so ma comunque
entra dentro la casa e parigino le tre
dita cosa ai giovani new haven l'one fur
free will have you by my side non ho
capito non ricordo se tenuto correlato
finito ma che lo porti tutto c'è la
porta ma ce l'ho fatta
no dai non è vero dimmi che non è vero
ci ho fatto sto casino per cosa
dai ragazzino per favore dai allora dal
cuore a pasto barbour così di fare
scusami così effetto peso dai ma l'avevo
mai vista se mi raccomando che vivono
delle bombe che a un certo punto abbiamo
che fionde la buona marchetto dai dovete
vado ok ma come salto a stato dentro
sito ha detto 60 21 quando d'altra parte
di poligono recitano dicono so perché ok
io non ho nessun tipo di bomba ho detto
loro formato da loro no no no anche
particolare si può fare ok tela lanci
sui piedi e poi corri con un puledro
impazzito bravissimo grazie grazie anche
non ci riservi un vero step sarà nostri
mettili cultura la bomba della l'anci è
esattamente guarda guarda completamente
in basso la lancio per coordinati salti
bravo perfetto
però non è vero ora si guarda con tutte
lo meriti sei ancora vivo come ciao
amico amico mio
c'è una trappola dopo di vederla
l'avremmo presa insieme alla trappola o
no non so cosa dire va bene vado a
prendere lo vado a prendere un attimo
occhio mi devo prendere e poi madonna
orribile ce l'ho fatta mica c'è un c'è
poi ti prego sito che cosa che c'è di
qua forever forever non core di forever
in sigla forever è vero tutto qua tutto
qua tutto qua amico tutto qua tutto qua
o al di là di qua ma cala r sì mamma bio
loro a proprio loro che non è finita qua
però proviamoci
red bull cross game
se come dobbiamo fare esattamente quello
che abbiamo fatto perché non lo so non
lo so amico non so non so violo dal no
ti prego senza aspettando che modi
questa altro non ci credo giusto
bravo bravo no sei morto ma ripreso c'è
qualche tempo le gare sotto la personale
di milano giù un drop cosa di fare
quadro scusami non ho capito neanch'io
cos'è un trofeo
non lo so o al contrario ma no ti devi
fermare si cosi se non cade e muore
ok a figo è un parkour ah ok un futuro
che organizza diventa difficile che sono
sottili cosi vabbè in teoria è fattibile
celano paesi si sembra che sia
abbastanza tesi convoglio tempi sono
schiantato alla fine però sono vivo
amico c'è una cosa che dovresti vedere
un secondo sam arriva lo faccio vedere
arriva un secondo che sono in vieni che
ti faccio vedere
nemmeno la tua anche perché ho paura di
questa cosa
allora quello è il liceo classico posso
morire anche un'altra volta prende da
qua per favore no no no no no aspetta
aspettava mai per motivi non è che c'è
un'altra strada per caso speriamo ma c'è
un check point che i comici e fuori in
mezzo c'è quasi mai non lo sapevo allora
ve ne sia fattibile minimo magari
arrivarci da meno amara criminale per
favore non avevamo poche parole della
donna si sono però perché non ferma
basta no sì sì sì sì l'ho fatto l'ho
fatto l'ho fatto mamma mia pietro fanna
via vai vai vai trigun grazie ai passi
sei un grande grazie ragazzi ha
veramente adoro per la prima volta che
posso dire ok sono sul finale tipico
temi che può aiutarmi
amico ce l'ho fatta a vico ce l'ha fatta
ma tornare gama ma no ma no ma infatti
io voglio uscire di costo gioco orribile
stronger than ever
ecco cosa bisogna fare spiega mi devi
stare qua serata gran muro sarà è vero
guardare bravo un nuovo vista entra in
tra poco c'è un altro puzzle un puzzle e
poi cercherò nell'altro curatoriale
l'altra santo si può
ma c'è un altro pezzo del puzzle infatti
c'è una grata impulso ciao
guardami guardami ti prego guardami che
se non capisci è brevissimo guardami per
spiegarti come si salta sta roba per la
piazza qua e corri più piano capirla
potevo farlo e così vediamo
no no a ganna difficilissimo però ho
capito c'è più o meno una parte che
veramente di figure di averne almeno 34
c'è l'ultima cortese non sa come fare
anche senza prove più facile quando hai
capito
bravissimo apple che ora devi metterti
al limite e piazzart era io me la piazza
sul muro e dentro di spingere i granata
impulso perché saltare le tante non
funzionano a quanto pare ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta te la devi tirare dritta
quindi che c'è un checkpoint ti prego
dimmi che c'è dimmi che c'è dimmi che
c'è un check point dove il check point
to point aspetto che forse una trappola
annuncia tra poco c'è check point amico
dai dai dai delle ultime credito
difficile abbia finito
no si era finita come si sente di fare
parkour qua posto di precorrere far away
from you because they want you never be
able to just buffon non so niente di
quello che ho letto però faceva rima
e le gratis ecco mi guarda mi è proprio
lui il fattore piripicchio e poi sul
braccio e l'onore di entrare nel centro
creativo di questo motto signori era
finiscono rete mentale scape mamma mia
non è facile guarda che non la pensavo
così difficile adesso abbiamo due detto
no scherzo con i ragazzi sanno che vi
sia piaciuto l'ingresso bompietro parola
mi ha accompagnato in questi episodi
bellissimi come al solito si è vissuto
lasciato un bel commento un bel like noi
ci vediamo come sempre a numerose novità
se trovassi il telecomando mentre faccio
finta di guardare la videocamera senza
cercarlo bella ragazza
[Musica]